hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut ich habe vor
ungefähr zehn tagen mal wieder was
relativ interessant ist glaube ich
obwohl ich bestellt und sowieso mal ab
und zu mal da unterwegs und schaue ob es
etwas neues gibt wasser und essen kann
für videos im letzten mission viejo habe
ich ja auch gesagt dass ich das jetzt
öfter wieder machen möchte und ja ganz
oben kam mir irgendwie so oder so was
ist das denn wir haben hier ich fand es
eigentlich ganz cool zumindest klingt es
ganz cool ihr könnt jetzt auch schon
sehen und zwar ist das die news game
stick 2.4 g1 wireless konsole man muss
ja ganz klar sagen auf den ersten blick
sieht das aus wie eine playstation 2
zumindest die controller und ja
eigentlich ganz nice ich kann euch das
kurz mal zeigen lasst euch bitte nicht
von dieser einen bewertung hier
irritieren die ist irgendwie keine
ahnung die gibt es gar nicht also ich
hab das ding gekauft und habe
expressversand bezahlt nicht kommt hat
es 980 euro kostet der preis hat sich an
scheint wieder geändert das ding hier
zum beispiel bei auch neu aber da war
ich mir jetzt ein bisschen unsicher dass
sie relativ ähnlich aus dort natürlich
auch keine ahnung also es erinnert halt
schon direkt an der playstation wir
gehen hier mal die bilder durch so hier
haben wir dann wieder diese beiden
controller die auch wieder extrem so
aussehen die playstation 2 controller
ich kann mich noch erinnern die
playstation 2 ich hatte selber nie eine
aber ein freund von mir und da war ich
immer so froh wenn ich daran spielen
konnte oder ich hab immer so singstar
gespielt 64er walter hierfür da kann man
auch echt nicht mehr kann dann aber hat
mich letztendlich dann doch hier für
diesen stick entschieden einfach weil
man den so gut mitnehmen kann und ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich glaube
natürlich nicht dass es qualitativ jetzt
hier der nächste schritt ist aber
trotzdem hat sich neugierig gemacht und
da muss auch sagen dass dingen soll
einfach 3500 verschiedene spiele drauf
haben und was ja cool ist du kannst dich
einfach eine tolle strecken wenn man auf
reisen mitnehmen so wie ich das auch
morgen tun werdet wir packen das paket
ist erstmal ausgespart ein video das
paket ist angekommen express das ging
ich glaube sieben tage hat es gedauert
haben heute jetzt dienstag eigentlich
ist das schon eine freitag an konsolen
hat er noch ich war auch erstaunt
gewesen und jetzt bin ich dann doch mal
gespannt wie das aussieht und ob sich
die 980 euro lohn durch das aus ihr
könnt es als erstes richtig hier khd
zwei controller also die controller
sehen halte guck mal hier also wir haben
hier in der mitte denn game stick und
wir haben hier ein playstation 2
schneider und hier noch ein plätzchen
frei und polak dabei der unterschied zu
playstation 3 konsolen ist dass die hier
weil es sind auf einer playstation 2 war
nichts noch nicht ich musste auf seine
playstation 2 hatte ich nie da war ich
noch zu jung da durfte ich so was nicht
haben und wahrscheinlich batterien oder
ok
ob es also ich bin wirklich mal extrem
gespannt ob man hier mit spaß haben kann
das hier ist dann der games stick ans
hier abziehen mit hdmi-anschluss schon
bei den fernseher ein und hier sollen
nach 3500 verschiedene games drauf sein
das finde ich schon ultra heftig weilt
er legt auch so ein bisschen und
bisschen billig wird falls mal in meine
wohnung und dann test ist ich habe er
sofort feierabend ich bin gespannt mal
gucken vielleicht wird ja wirklich
leisten gamestop früher mal gezockt hab
ich wollte eigentlich um spielpartner
der mir spielt aber ich denke da finde
ich für heute bis gleich leute das geht
ich bin mittlerweile in münchen
irgendwie habe ich nicht mehr auf der
kette bekommen dass wir zuhause zu
testen ich bin hier auf jeden fall
morgen auf der messe wir sind jetzt
schon den hotel maries autor die ist nur
gerade heuer statt ich dachte mir aber
das video muss ich jetzt mal raus hauen
und deswegen hab ich das ding einfach
mitgenommen ist liegt auf dem tisch die
verhassten tisch ist ich bin ein
bisschen verwirrt wir haben wir lange
fahrt unter uns habe ich gerade hier
diesen kasten fernseh abgebaut damit ich
den game stick den habe ich euch auch
schon gezeigt hier ist jetzt noch so
eine wireless transmitter ran gekommen
damit ich das halt dann steuern kann mit
den controllern und jetzt versuche ich
den auf jeden fall mal hin und zu
installieren dem fernseher mal gucken
was passiert das ist leider gar nicht
mal so leicht weil ich musste die ferse
jetzigen hieraus ziehen
ich hoffe du wirst doch nicht kaputt die
noch einfach hier
ich hasse das auch manchmal diese scheiß
hdmi anschlüsse in frankreich den
fernseher zunächst sind wir haben hier
wirklich fast kein signal warum den kein
signal leute ich habe noch leichte
technische schwierigkeiten wenn ich das
problem behoben habe dann werde ich mich
hier ich bring euch wirklich fast
hierdurch leute passt auf das passt so
gut zu mir komm wir nehmen das
hochspannungskabel um das gar nichts und
das brauche ich auch noch ich bin so ein
trottel alter alles klappt sofort wenn
man leute ich habe es endlich geschafft
okay jetzt machen wir die tagesthemen
mal aus und zwischen auf hdmi zwei bitte
funktionieren
jawoll alter geht doch jetzt war ich mal
kurz auf marie und dann stelle ich immer
in meine neue spielekonsole vor und euch
dann auch wir haben auf jeden fall
ziemlich viele retro games magic 2 alter
da ist wirklich jede menge drauf mit
dragon balls ist interessant wie viele
games auch so einen kleinen stick sind
ne leute ich oder wir testen jetzt mal
und mich gleich wieder aber erste
eindruck der stimmt schon mal ich hab
mir das schon gedacht dass das eher
ältere spiele sein werden aber egal ich
finde das gar nicht so schlecht nur
jetzt passt mal auf die leute also ich
will immer noch sonnig ein paar jahre
vielleicht kennt das ja der ein oder
andere von euch man muss eigentlich nur
mit dem flugzeug fliegen und ich glaube
das hat schon spaß mal vor wenn man zu
zweit spielt das ding ist nur die
störung hat manchmal ein bisschen rein
anderen stelle die richtung wechselt
dann flop das halt so und reagiert nicht
richtig man kann diesen scheiß kugel
nicht immer ausreichen ein letztes mal
guckt jetzt hat die steuerung geht gar
nicht gut zu hören hey das ist manchmal
einer fast unmöglich ist sich eher als
bin ich wieder voll reingeflogen diese
hier und als der panzer command super
alex ganz stark jetzt kommen denke ich
mal die nächsten flugzeuge und
boden nicht anders ihr wird rasiert ihr
könnt sehen com panzer weg mit dir
stabile leistung
[Musik]
ich muss sagen leute ich werde besser
das war schon eine gute und gerade diese
kamera ist so nahm das networking keine
detail camp also ich habe gerade mal
geguckt es gibt sogar super mario super
mario bros 32 also noch mal echt dass
der genauen blick wir mal statt
[Musik]
das ist aber ein schwieriges level
muss wahrscheinlich einfach nach hinten
wirken die
kleinen mitglieder den pilzen
ein konzert kleckern jetzt eben
hochklettern können
du hättest du
schatz breitesten wahrscheinlich als
opfer nehmen müssen halt ist auf den
aufspringenden dann hoch also schon
zeitlich gar nicht so schlecht so marita
und sagen was du kannst ja
[Musik]
oh
oh oh das ist gefährlich aus
[Musik]
alter du hast es geschafft nicht
schlecht und hat das spaß gemacht oder
eher nicht
also leute ich muss man gut festhalten
ich habe mir das ding dann etwas anders
vorgestellt wahrscheinlich stand der
beschreibung das ist ausschließlich so
alte retro spiele sind weil ich dachte
halt da wäre auch so moderne spiele
drauf die man halt gegen alles machen
kann aber die grafik lässt zu wünschen
übrig wir werden das auf jeden fall
jetzt noch ein bisschen weiter testen
weil wir nichts besseres zu tun aber
mein erster eindruck ist auch das ist
wirklich nicht schlecht ist und man ist
sehr klein man kann sie überall mit
hinnehmen das macht spaß glaube ich also
jetzt aufpasste machen welche konsole
erinnert sich der controller playstation
2 hattest du die nicht mal
jeder einfach pokémon blattgrün oh mein
gott marie dieses spiel hat mein leben
verändert
marie die sich viel hat mein leben
verändert weißt du was
lasst uns das besser nicht starten
dieses spiel habe ich zum geburtstag
bekommt das hat früher 55 euro kostet
nur dieses spiel alter nein
ich habe gänsehaut
jetzt muss ich erst mal meinen start
pokémon wählen ist alles auf chinesisch
man kann ja verstehen wie heißt lea ist
severin
professor nein ich finde das ringen in
den charts das ist mit eines der wenigen
sachen die ich jemals gesagt habe ruhig
kauft euch dass alle die pokemon
blattgrün kennen müssen meinen daumen
nach oben geben ich weiß gar nicht ob
viele von euch dafür noch jungen aber
ich glaube eigentlich nicht bester
sketchen aus alabaster leute mit dieser
geilen poker musik hintergrund würde ich
sagen ich habe keinen fall habe ich das
video hochladen weil irgendwie ist das
nicht mehr der qualitative anspruch den
ich habe aber wenn es cool wird und
irgendwie dieses produkt ist wirklich
ganz neues ladens tod deswegen leute ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen dass die
daumen nach oben da wir den kanal wir
sehen uns haben drei leute